I was wrong for my actions that took  place on Wednesday and for that um you  know I have apologized to my team  um I have apologized to Jordan and you  know  um I wanted to take that a step further  uh you know with  with the event yesterday uh with the  video leaking  um there's a there is a  a  um huge embarrassment that comes with  that not not only for myself as as I was  the one that committed the action the  embarrassment that comes for me is what  it is and that's something that I have  to deal with but the embarrassment uh  the Jordan has to deal with and that  this team has to deal with this  organization has to deal with but also  Jordan's family